[Musique]
là
ouais
[Musique]
patience est un plat qui se mange sans
sousse
[Musique]
alors comme ça vous voulez vous
installer ici j'ai surtout besoin d'être
ambitieux
[Musique]
ton père étude a ajouté je crois qu'ils
composaient son oeuvre ultime avant de
mourir une sonate et si cette oeuvre
était devenu une telle obsession pour
mon père j'aimerais savoir pourquoi
[Musique]
j'ai vu des ombres des silhouettes
il ya c est franche symbole
quelque chose ne va pas avec cette
musique
elle ouvre la porte des ténèbres c'est
magique
ces notes ou le pouvoir d'invoquer lors
du christ
plus qu'une musique
petit chat tu n'entends pas
jo
[Musique]
ton monde n'est pas le seul qui existe
il y en a un autre obscur et secret
tu as la capacité d'entrer dans ce monde
commence poursuit mme tu es lié au mal à
son pouvoir
la différence entre le rêve et la
réalité était nu parfois
que se passe-t-il si vous n'avez
vraiment aucune parole
[Musique]
qui est cette fille vous pouvez la voir
aussi que voulez vous dire
ce
[Musique]
bonjour tout le monde ça va besoin alors
moi vous voyez j'ai juste de me
réveiller mais je suis déjà à l'arraché
restée presse il faut voilà j'ai un site
d'arrivée au studio one vient de poster
la photo en moins d'une minute me like
j'étais teste sa fille
comment ça tu l'as détestant fait ça
veut dire quelle secte est addict aux
par tabac tue à planter ta voiture huit
fois ce mois-ci ya aujourd'hui mes posts
ont généré plus d'un millier de plaques
et pour moi c'est sa coupe mais la vie
c'est bien pour quelque chose qui a du
succès sur les réseaux sociaux pas la
vie qui paie mes factures de stream
tally tout le monde j'espère que vous
allez bien
berthier ski lara non je crois qu'on
devrait se séparer qu'est ce qui te
prend calme-toi tout est sous contrôle
oui mon portable tu vas aller dans un
endroit où il n'y a pas de raisons
poussent à jupiter
[Musique]
et je crois que dans les films c'est là
où tu te souviens que ça fait très
longtemps que tu attendais ce moment et
on s'embrasse
aujourd'hui tu va m'aider à l'atelier et
votre petite fille elle s'habitue
[Musique]
j'ai enfin je m'appelle anar les
raccompagnait lâché elle risque et
imagine comment et ma vie des milliers
de personnes me suivre sur les réseaux
et moi ce que je fais tous les jours
mais y'en a pas une seule qui me connaît
vraiment je veux trouver ma voie faire
quelque chose qui m'intéresse vraiment
et apprendre à mieux me connais ma
chérie mieux se connaître c'est le
meilleur moyen de se détester
[Musique]
monde sait que je suis qu'une snobinarde
irresponsable non je suis pas d'accord
c'est pas vrai tu dis ça c'est parce que
tu me connais pas trop encore chérie tu
pourras mais dieu que le contrat de la
succursale à ce jeu comprend rien
maintenant j'aimerais que tu veux pas
aller à l'école
non non non et les olivades maman j'ai
eu mon sac de cours moi c'est les
enfants tout le temps les enfants
sauvages faculté à déposer à l'école les
enfants et à toutes les journées pour
tout peters à ma cité rieus la jeune
reine important que pour être en place
vraiment tout est noté tous les plats
cuisinés pour ce soir là sont déjà au
frigo
ensuite sur retourne à l'école et tu
déposes les enfants avant tout à gauche
un os et aux droits
oui mais où est la droite droite ensuite
tu me retourne chercher maxime qui
s'attendent bras chez son copain les
ondes mais ça va passer de la sécurité
on a ensuite suffi avec joseph c
qui vont aller
et crise et moi mais il ya combien de
marche que moi ça allait travailler là
maintenant je sais où tu dois avoir un
papa c'est votre faute qui décide
ça c'est lundi d'une tonne la chance
parce que c'est un jour calme maintenant
le mardi
renchérit première règle fille à ton
papa qu'est ce que tu as à exportable
aucun résultat pour comment gérer
premier raid le fille
je suis rentré chez moi à john trouver
je comprends que le comportement de jude
puisse vous inquiéter c'est une peluche
c'est une telle violence je vous
conseille de lui trouver un endroit où
ils se sentent en sécurité
je pense que ça lui ferait du bien ça
doit être le bâtiment principal du bien
à john
qui est ce charmant garçon tu seras nom
pareil il me l'a dit me racontent plein
de choses
il savait que votre fils
le trouverai je t'aime maman je t'aime
aussi quelque chose lui arrive
[Applaudissements]
d'accord croisé finito relate pinocchio
taille des fois comme ça monswiller boca
un turban m dibaba
pas bon manon campignol mais s'intéresse
aux pièces un atout fini en hausse ont
dû mettre de babi yar khan iv à jérôme
être fade à medad
ciao filiale omis ocha square la une a
co promoteur tenait un café ni d'eau ni
john magee des riches note el bab
le continent maudit
michaud
à quoi bon rythme
le combat
mon père est belle tu dis un mot de
passe et des balaurs
asham en appliquant la matière
tél